In this video, we'll
discuss the method
of hierarchical clustering.
In hierarchical
clustering, the clusters
are formed by each data point
starting in its own cluster.
As a small example, suppose
we have five data points.
Each data point is labeled as
belonging in its own cluster.
So this data point's in
the red cluster, this one's
in the blue cluster, this
one's in the purple cluster,
this one's in the green
cluster, and this one's
in the yellow cluster.
Then hierarchical clustering
combines the two nearest
clusters into one cluster.
We'll use Euclidean
and Centroid distances
to decide which two
clusters are the closest.
In our example, the
green and yellow clusters
are closest together.
So we would combine these two
clusters into one cluster.
So now the green
cluster has two points,
and the yellow cluster is gone.
Now this process repeats.
We again find the
two nearest clusters,
which this time are the green
cluster and the purple cluster,
and we combine them
into one cluster.
Now the green cluster
has three points,
and the purple cluster is gone.
Now the two nearest clusters
are the red and blue clusters.
So we would combine
these two clusters
into one cluster,
the red cluster.
So now we have just two
clusters, the red one
and the green one.
So now the final step is to
combine these two clusters
into one cluster.
So at the end of
hierarchical clustering,
all of our data points
are in a single cluster.
The hierarchical
cluster process can
be displayed through
what's called a dendrogram.
The data points are
listed along the bottom,
and the lines show how the
clusters were combined.
The height of the lines
represents how far
apart the clusters were
when they were combined.
So points 1 and 4
were pretty close
together when they
were combined.
But when we combined the
two clusters at the end,
they were significantly
farther apart.
We can use a dendrogram to
decide how many clusters we
want for our final
clustering model.
This dendrogram shows
the clustering process
with ten data points.
The easiest way to pick the
number of clusters you want
is to draw a horizontal
line across the dendrogram.
The number of vertical
lines that line crosses
is the number of
clusters there will be.
In this case, our line
crosses two vertical lines,
meaning that we will have
two clusters-- one cluster
with points 5, 2, and 7, and
one cluster with the remaining
points.
The farthest this
horizontal line
can move up and down
in the dendrogram
without hitting one of
the horizontal lines
of the dendrogram,
the better that choice
of the number of clusters is.
If we instead selected
three clusters,
this line can't move
as far up and down
without hitting horizontal
lines in the dendrogram.
This probably means that the
two cluster choice is better.
But when picking the
number of clusters,
you should also consider
how many clusters
make sense for the
particular application
you're working with.
After selecting the number
of clusters you want,
you should analyze your clusters
to see if they're meaningful.
This can be done by
looking at basic statistics
in each cluster, like the mean,
maximum, and minimum values
in each cluster
and each variable.
You can also check to
see if the clusters have
a feature in common that was
not used in the clustering,
like an outcome variable.
This often indicates
that your clusters
might help improve
a predictive model.
In the next video, we'll
cluster our movies by genre,
and then analyze
our clusters to see
how they can be used to
perform content filtering.